okay now here's vivid proof that some
people will do anything for a thrill Oh
enough if you don't like giraffe tongues
you should probably look away now
this is a keeper at the on of Africa
park in Camp Verde Arizona demonstrating
one very personal way of feeding a
giraffe so why would a draft need such a
long time
giraffes tongue is very long thin they
can be 50 centimeters or 20 inches long
but they're like that for a very good
reason drives our browser animals so
they browse amongst trees their height
means that can get very high up but
that's not enough some of the tree they
like to browse on our acacia trees which
have all this really sharp spines in
order to try and stop animals eating
their voltage so the giraffes long
tongue can reach in between those spines
and grip the leaf and tear it off so
that you're after ages and it's not the
type of demonstration our scientists
would ever do
I would kiss a giraffe in a heartbeat I
absolutely would except for Karen
apparently